now as you got into some good  conversations before you gave him I  found that the Quran the Quranic remedy  was the solution and trust in the Quran  impacted me to the point that didn't  leave me with no doubt what had you  accept Islam what was in Barcelona had  you total Allah says al hamdulillah leve  Angela Rd Hilke Taba well I'm yellow I  was all praise is due to Allah the one  who has revealed the book and placed  therein no crookedness of scholars of  great reputable scholars in Islam have  ended up being not Arabs yes which you  said you wanted to submit your will to  the creator that's  ie that Islam I've read on that how is  it a filtration system and from among  these ayats his signs is your different  languages than your colors so these are  the signs of Allah even if you are not  spanish-speaking know that in America in  major cities Latinos are becoming a  majority